bonjour michel combeau merci de répondre
à notre invitation des enchères pour la
5g alors que le réseau 4g n'est pas
encore intégralement couverts ce n'est
pas un peu précipité
donc ce qu effectivement l'objectif des
opérateurs est bien de faire les deux à
la fois à savoir achever la couverture
du territoire en 4g
c'est l'objet du new deal l'accord signé
au début du mois de janvier 2018 avec
l'état et l'arcep qui doit nous amener
d'ici à la fin de l'année 2022 a passé
l'intégralité du réseau en 4g est de
construire de nouveaux pylônes dans ces
fameuses zones blanches 1 est donc bien
entendu la 5g va progressivement se
déployer sur le territoire national en
même temps que nous achèverons la
couverture des zones blanches en pêtre g
il ya beaucoup de défiance en ce moment
vers la 5g craintes sanitaires angoisse
écologique la future autoroute numérique
et quand même semé d'embûches
vous comprenez toutes ces inquiétudes
oui ces inquiétudes sont légitimes elles
le sont à chaque fois qu'une technologie
sans fil a été déployé à ne l'avons
connue pour la 2g pour la 3g pour la 4g
est maintenant pour la 5g
la france dispose dispose du cadre
réglementaire et de concertation parmi
les plus abouties au monde un à chaque
déploiement d'antennes
nous fournissons un dossier
d'information au maire et bien entendu
dans la constatation pour verrait pour
vraiment savoir si la 5g n'est pas
dangereuse en effectivement diraient les
études sanitaires font l'objet d'un
centre d'études 1 par le gouvernement il
faut rappeler un plus de 17 autorités
sanitaires dans le monde n'ont pas
trouvé effectivement d'un pacte pour la
santé en provenance des antennes 5g
c'est donc en toute confiance surtout
pour des fréquences qui sont utilisées
depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années en
france que les passagers sera lancé dans
les prochaines semaines on a énoncé
précédemment la 5g cd voiture autonome
des opérations chirurgicales
télécommandé on a parlé de la peur
écologique de la peur sanitaires mais
aussi l'angoissé sur le numérique qui
pourrait prendre le pas sur sur le réel
c'est effectivement un enjeu sur les
usages au quotidien
nous l'avons vu lors de manière assez
paradoxale pendant la crise sanitaire
avec les besoins de connectivité accrue
le dirait des gens pour étudier ou
travailler mais nous avons ou plus a
appelé aussi à une usage raisonnable à
l'époque pour ne pas saturer les réseaux
et 7
effectivement cette réflexion sur les
usages est indispensable avec la 5g ce
soit en matière de protection des
données personnelles en terme de temps
d'écran ou tout simplement des usages du
numérique au quotidien et c'est
l'ensemble de ces effectivement de ces
conseils un kit se seront l'objet de
concertation avec les citoyens dans les
prochains mois vous parlez de soins de
prévention ça veut dire c'est ça bien
entendu un autre enjeu effectivement de
réfléchir au delà de la simple
technologie de réfléchir aux bons usages
effectivement du portable par exemple
nous avons désiré d'importantes actions
pour envers les jeunes on le sait
parfois les jeunes peuvent être plus
sensible à l'usagé d'internet
nous avons donc un travail particulier
par exemple autour du cyberharcèlement
avec les jeunes et donc la 5g de nous
amener à renforcer cette réflexion sur
les usages et donc sur l'utilisation de
la technologie baissent nos logis n'est
pas bonne ou mauvaise en soi c'est son
usage qui doit être effectivement appris
enfin les gens doivent s'approprier ces
cet usage au bénéfice de tous
mais michel combeau on parle aussi de 2
milliards pour l'état au final est-ce
que c'est pas une question de gros sous
finalement la faune que j'ai c'est une
question de développement économique
pour les entreprises c'est vrai que
l'état via les enchères va récupérer
plus de 2 milliards d'euros
c'est aussi l'état valorise le
patrimoine des fréquences et le valorise
après avec des investissements notamment
pour les entreprises
c'est vrai que la 5g c'est avant tout un
outil de développement industriel très
important en ces temps de crise
économique
pour permettre aux entreprises
françaises de faire la différence dans
une concurrence mondiale
monaco est le seul pays entièrement
couvert par la 5g tous les monégasques
ont des téléphones dernière génération
compatible
pourtant le marché ne foisonnent pas de
terminaux susceptible de fonctionner
avec la 5g
c'est pas un peu mettre la charrue avant
les boeufs fabien moment initié le
cercle parce que s'il n'y a pas de
réseau les terminaux singer ne serviront
à rien voilà donc il faut bien commencer
à déployer en fonction de priorités il
ya déjà un centre de terminaux 5 g qui
sont disponibles et plus arriveront dans
les prochaines semaines mais c'est bien
l'ouverture du réseau sur le territoire
national qui va permettre effectivement
au constructeur de vendre leurs nouveaux
terminaux 5 g il faut donc initié
effectivement l'ouverture des réseaux
pour que le cercle vertueux ensuite se
mettre en place sur notre territoire
national on va à côté de vous des images
de huawei on sait que le géant chinois
des télécommunications est en avance sur
la 5g
mais washington ou londres se sont
montés montré hostile vis-à-vis de
huawei est ce que pour paris c'est un
jeu d'équilibriste diplomatiquement
parlant ne pas froisser le marché
chinois et puis en même temps avoir la
5g en france on le rappelle un peu les
opérateurs il est important de pour
s'appuyer sur l'ensemble des
équipementiers pour développer ces
nouveaux services à l'ensemble des
équipementiers sont dirait présent en
france le seront au moins au début du
déploiement de la 5g il est vrai que
pour les opérateurs et bien cette
concurrence entre équipementiers une
concurrence mondiale est bénéfique ce
qu'elle permet aux français de
bénéficier de l'ensemble de ces nouveaux
services et à chaque équipementier de se
réinventer pour les opérateurs puissent
ensuite offrir les meilleurs services et
donc ce choix est indispensable pour les
opérateurs et pour les français
afin de disposer des meilleurs services
merci michel combeau d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur général de la fédération des
télécoms